there are these two guys sitting
together in a bar in the remote alaskan
wilderness
one of the guys is religious the other
is an atheist and the two are arguing
about the existence of god with that
special intensity that comes after about
the fourth beard
and the atheist says look it's not like
i don't have actual reasons for not
believing in god it's not like i haven't
ever experimented with the whole god and
prayer thing
just last month i got caught away from
camp in that terrible blizzard and i was
totally lost and i couldn't see a thing
and it was 50 below and so i tried it i
fell to my knees in the snow and cried
out oh god if there is a god i'm lost in
this blizzard and i'm going to die if
you don't help me
and now in the bar the religious guy
looks at the atheist all puzzled
well then you must believe now he says
after all here you are alive
the atheist just rolls his eyes no man
all that was was a couple eskimos
happened to come wandering by and they
showed me the way back to king
it's easy to run the story through a
kind of standard liberal arts analysis
the exact same experience can mean two
totally different things to two
different people given those people's
two different belief templates and two
different ways of constructing meaning
from experience
because we prize tolerance and diversity
of belief
nowhere in our liberal arts analysis do
we want to claim that one guy's
interpretation is true and the other
guys is false or bad
which is fine except we also never end
up talking about just where these
individual templates and beliefs come
from
meaning where they come from inside the
two guys
as if a person's most basic orientation
toward the world and the meaning of his
experience were somehow just hardwired
like height or shoe size
or automatically absorbed from the
culture like language
as if how we construct meaning we're not
actually a matter of personal
intentional choice
plus there's the matter of arrogance
the non-religious guy is so totally
certain
in his dismissal of the possibility that
the passing eskimos had anything to do
with his prayer for help
true there are plenty of religious
people who seem arrogantly certain of
their own interpretations too
they're probably even more repulsive
than atheists
at least to most of us
but religious dogmatist problem is
exactly the same as the stories
unbeliever blind certainty
a closed-mindedness that amounts to an
imprisonment so total that the prisoner
doesn't even know he's locked up
the point here is that i think this is
one part of what teaching me how to
think is really supposed to mean to be
just a little less arrogant
to have just a little critical awareness
about myself and my certainties
because a huge percentage of the stuff
that i tend to be automatically certain
of is it turns out totally wrong and
deluded
i have learned this the hard way here is
just one example of the total wrongness
of something i tend to be automatically
sure of
everything in my own immediate
experience supports my deep belief that
i am the absolute center of the universe
the realest most vivid and important
person in existence
we rarely talk about this sort of
natural basic self-centeredness because
it's so socially repulsive but it's
pretty much the same for all of us
it is our default setting hardwired into
our boards at birth
think about it there is no experience
you have had that you are not at the
absolute center of
the world as you experience it is there
in front of you or behind you
to the left or right of you
on your tv or your monitor and so on
other people's thoughts and feelings
have to be communicated to you somehow
but your own are so immediate urgent
real
please don't worry that i'm getting
ready to lecture you about compassion or
other directedness or all the so-called
virtues
this is not a matter of virtue it's a
matter of my choosing to do the work of
somehow altering or getting free of my
natural hardwired default setting which
is to be deeply and literally
self-centered
and to see and interpret everything
through this lens of self
people who can adjust their natural
default setting this way are often
described as being well adjusted
which i suggest to you is not an
accidental term
learning how to think really means
learning how to exercise some control
over how and what you think
it means being conscious and aware
enough to choose what you pay attention
to and to choose how you construct
meaning from experience
because if you cannot exercise this kind
of choice in adult life you will be
totally
think of the old cliche about quote the
mind being an excellent servant but a
terrible master
this like many cliches so lame and
unexciting on the surface actually
expresses a great and terrible truth
it is not the least bit coincidental
that adults who commit suicide with
firearms almost always shoot themselves
in
the head
they shoot the terrible master
and the truth is that most of these
suicides are actually dead long before
they pull the trigger
in the day-to-day trenches of adult life
there is actually no such thing as
atheism
there is no such thing as not worshiping
everybody worships
the only choice we get is what to
worship
and a compelling reason for maybe
choosing some sort of god or spiritual
type thing to worship
be it jc or allah be it yahweh or the
wicked mother goddess or the four noble
truths or some inviolable set of ethical
principles is that pretty much anything
else you worship will eat you alive
if you worship money and things if they
are where you tap real meaning in life
then you will never have enough never
feel you have enough it's the truth
worship your own body and beauty and
sexual allure and you will always feel
ugly
and when time and age start showing you
will die a million deaths before they
finally plant you
on one level we all know this stuff
already
it's been codified as myths proverbs
cliches
epigrams parables
the skeleton of every great story
the whole trick is keeping the truth up
front in daily consciousness
worship power you will end up feeling
weak and afraid and you will need ever
more power over others to numb you to
your own fear
worship your intellect being seen as
smart
you will end up feeling stupid a fraud
always on the verge of being found out
look the insidious thing about these
forms of worship is not that they're
evil or sinful it is that they are
unconscious they are default settings
they're the kind of worship you just
gradually slip into day after day
getting more and more selective about
what you see and how you measure value
without ever being fully aware that
that's what you're doing
and the so-called real world will not
discourage you from operating on your
default settings
because the so-called real world of men
and money and power comes merrily along
on the fuel of fear and anger and
frustration and craving and the worship
of self
our own present culture has harnessed
these forces in ways that have yielded
extraordinary wealth and comfort and
personal freedom
the freedom all to be lords of our own
tiny skull-sized kingdoms alone at the
center of all creation
this kind of freedom has much to
recommend it
but of course there are all different
kinds of freedom and the kind that is
most precious you will not hear much
talked about much in the great outside
world of wanting and achieving and
displaying
the really important kind of freedom
involves attention
and awareness
and discipline
and being able truly to care about other
people and to sacrifice for them over
and over
in myriad petty little unsexy ways every
day
that is real freedom
that is being educated and understanding
how to think
the alternative is unconsciousness the
default setting the rat race
the constant gnawing sense of having had
and lost some infinite thing
i know that this stuff probably doesn't
sound fun and breezy or grandly
inspirational the way a commencement
speech is supposed to sound
what it is as far as i can see is the
capital t truth with a whole lot of
rhetorical niceties stripped away
you are of course free to think of it
whatever you wish
but please don't just dismiss it as some
finger wagging dr laura sermon
none of this stuff is really about
morality or religion or dogma or big
fancy questions of life after death the
capital t truth is about life before
death
it is about the real value of a real
education which has almost nothing to do
with knowledge and everything to do with
simple awareness
it is unimaginably hard to do this
to stay conscious and alive in the adult
world day in and day out
which means yet another grand cliche
turns out to be true your education
really is the job of a lifetime
you